so which ones actually affect change in
our life and slow down the aging process
as you've seen in some studies now that
you've analyze them yeah so there's
there's a few that have a great amount
of evidence behind them so I'm gonna I'm
gonna go through five I've got some
notes here so I've got five um which is
funny actually when I called in to your
to your podcast you know a few months
ago um I had written out three of them
and then the caller right before had
mentioned two of them yeah which which
really robbed me of my my my thunder but
anyway um so the first one which I'm
sure a lot of people are really aware of
is creatine that one has hundreds I mean
literally hundreds of studies behind it
and it's it's incredibly efficacious I
think one area that people don't talk
about though is that there's new
research coming out on Creatine
specifically for uh memory and its
effects on our brain yeah so beyond what
we green we talk about that a few times
now uh yeah so I looked over that
literature and it seems like creatine
has a beneficial impact on our nervous
system as a whole so no matter who it is
everybody gets a benefit from creating
on the nervous system um of course
there's going to be always exceptions
like people that have specific
conditions it might not work or it may
worse and things but by and large we're
talking about the average person um so
creatine has an effect on the nervous
system it has an additive effect on
memory in people who are older so people
who are over the age of 65 um so that's
that's one supplement of course that it
also has tremendous effects on our
musculature as well um the next one is
uh
curcumin which has a good amount of
research behind it I've I've been
focused mainly on the research on uh
diabetes risk and pre-diabetes so
preventing pre diabetes and preventing
diabetes and cumin actually has some
really powerful uh effects when it comes
to protecting us from diabetes that said
uh from that standpoint it's actually
not that effective for people who are
already healthy um
and I think from an inflammation
standpoint it could have positive
effects all around does it affect the C
reactive protein numbers on your blood
Labs yeah it does it has quite an effect
on a number of different inflam markers
you know what uh what daily dosage you'd
have to take for that yeah sure I've got
500 milligrams some studies go up to
1500 milligrams a day yeah it's not
toxic at high dosages anyway so you
could take 500 a th000 you probably be
fine no not that I'm aare and of course
the studies usually they don't they I
shouldn't say usually they never use a
dose that's going to end up being toxic
to people right what about the creatum
monohydrate what was it what was the
dose in the studies for that so for
women it's three grams for men it's five
grams um I think as more research comes
out there's several studies that have
used much higher levels use 20 grams a
day and um I think the reason why is
because the penetration so when when we
consume Creatine our body stops
producing creatine and I know the first
question that comes to people's minds is
well then is that a good thing um yeah I
thought we got creatine from Meats from
organ meats or from um tissues no we do
that we do that as well yeah that's
absolutely true but our bodies can
manufacture it too yeah our liver and
our kidneys send molecules back and
forth to one another that ultimately
create creatine then that gets absorbed
within our musculature and obviously the
other tissues as well okay and uh
actually our brain has its own unique
creatine production system and that's
actually why they a few Studies have
used 20 grams is because they think that
to saturate the brain with creatine um
you have to to consume more than the
typical muscle Centric 5 grams so that's
that's been the idea but um that hasn't
actually been verified yet so um as it
stands the the studies that I've seen
have shown an effect at five grams if
there's an additive an even better
effect at 20 grams I don't know that yet
and nobody does okay um the next one is
fish oil so 800 milligrams to about a
gram specifically so what I focused on
for f oil was to look at the effects
that it has on the brain um so
protective effects also on memory um and
our ability to learn language and just
like overall plasticity neuroplasticity
of the brain and specifically focusing
on DHA over EPA not to say that EPA
doesn't have positive effects but our
brain is has much much much higher I
think it's like 90% uh DHA and much less
EPA so focus in the studies therefore
focused a lot more on DHA and they
tended to find more of an effect if uh
people focused on DHA consumption so do
you know who um the author of
estrogeneration is Dr Anthony
J no but I've heard you speak about him
I think I've had him on my channel twice
and I've used him to analyze my DNA
which is something I'll get get to in a
minute when I get to my other talking
points but he but he did mention that
when he was in school the were analyzing
um the chemistry and the makeup of human
brains and I think it was an outrageous
number something like 80 or 90% of the
human brain is basically
DHA um so fish oils are like not just a
building block but it's necessary for
your brain to operate in his estimation
I'm guessing that you would say the same
uh absolutely um is there a source of
fish oil that you'd recommend because I
mean the problem with fish in the sea
that I came across is mercury content
there was a time when I was consuming
loads and loads of tuna and my mercury
levels went through the roof when I was
doing my blood labs and you know
doctor's like what have you been eating
I said I've been eating a lot of tuna
because my trainer wanted me to up my
protein and I wanted a convenient way so
I would go to Costco and get these
frozen tuna Pokey packs and I was legit
eating like two packs of these Tunas per
day for about four weeks and my my
Mercury level went through the roof he's
like it's an old fish old fish in the
sea have shitloads of mercury and metals
and stuff like that so is there a source
of fish oil that you'd recommend or even
krill oil like is there one that's
better than the other based on what
you've studied no I don't uh I don't
know that much about different brands
but what I can say is uh if you go to
Consumer Labs um I don't know if you're
remember there but it's really cheap
subscription they actually do all the
independent testing so they actually
have a lab where they do all the
independent testing and they they check
for mercury in all the fish oils that
they uh so all the products are on the
Shelf if you have a membership then
it'll tell you and rank it sort of thing
yeah they'll they'll rank it I mean they
test I don't know like maybe 30
different brands they test them every
like few years just to make sure that
they're staying up to to standard um
they check for mercury they T check for
arsenic they check for a bunch of
different things and then they'll give
you like three recommendations uh for
for what they they they think would be
uh beneficial okay um so I'll have to
look into that so that's one two three
what's number four uh glac which is
actually the one that I had mentioned to
you at one point um what was again it
was glycine plus netal
Cy so gine plus NAC yeah yeah um so
glac the the studies on glac have been
really impressive just genuinely
impressive from a really great research
group at a Baylor um school of medicine
and I was I was blown away and that's
actually one of the videos that did
really well on my channel um
just because going over the literature
was just metric after metric after
metric improved with GLX supplementation
but the the reason why I say but is
because I I think that glac is probably
only going to be effective for people
who are a little bit older so all the
studies were done in people that were in
their 70s and they saw a tremendous
benefit so again kind of like the
creatine situation with memory I think
that glac is probably going to be most
beneficial for people in their 60s and
70s and Beyond what sort of benefits
were 7y olds getting from it oh massive
it was all over so uh they did some
biochemical measures of mitochondrial
function they saw they experienced
betterment in mitochondrial function
which translates to better ability to
use fat for metabolism so they
experienced a betterment in their their
ability to use fat which also translates
typically to uh better insulin
sensitivity which they also found and
really dramatic effects they found
better uh grip strength uh muscle
performance in general uh muscle
endurance like and that's just like a
small subset of the things that they
tested there are only a few things that
didn't improve like uh uh I think like
triglycerides and cholesterol or
something like that but most of the
measures that they looked at really did
improve substantially what were the
dosages and it time of the day did they
dose them do you know so the time of the
day they just took it with meals if I
remember correctly just to avoid an
upset stomach mainly because it's
extremely acidic um but the dosages that
they used were absolutely astronomical
they were like something like six grams
I want to say seven grams for each um
and there have been some other studies
that have used Knack or anical cysteine
at lower dosages and seen positive
effects so um what I've been trending
towards uh what I told my dad at least
and my my grandparents is that uh
probably aiming for a smaller dose is
probably going to be fine because we we
don't actually know we only have three
studies on the topic um so and although
they're they're fantastic studies uh we
don't actually have like an upper limit
or a lower limit it's possible that we
could get all these benefits from one
gram a day you know we just don't know
so um and the thing with glac is that
because it's one research group and as
any scientists would say you kind of
want to see it replicated that said it's
not you know some random lab in the
middle of nowhere um it's a pretty
reputable lab so what's the
um um like are there any side effects to
it any live like damage to organs any
like does it tax or kidney values or
anything was it just totally fine
throughout yeah there was uh there was
one concerning Trend with GLX um I say
somewhat concerning because well I'll
get to it so the the one concerning
Trend was that there was an increase in
alt which is a enzyme that's found in
your liver and if you start seeing a lot
of that expressed or or released I
should say in the the bloodstream that's
typically a sign that you're
experiencing some level of liver
toxicity however uh the the rise was the
actual Delta so from before taking glac
to after taking glac over I think like I
don't know several months like four six
months something like that was really
small and additionally they did other
enzyme other liver enzymes that did not
change um so you know it's just one
metric and the other metrics that would
kind of have to go along with it uh
didn't change didn't it wasn't anything
that really caused for concern so I'm
keeping my eye on it but um it's as it
stands it's not like it shot straight up
and people were turning yellow or
anything like that okay so Glycine and
NAC um I do remember you mentioning I I
take that anyway but I haven't thought
about uh passing on to my parents
because they're elderly now and you know
it's like muscles are wasting they're
getting tired all the time so yeah if
it's got that much of an opportunity to
improve their quality of life then I'm
definitely going to get them some okay
and then number
five number five I've got collagen
peptides so I've only gonna ask you
about
collagen okay yeah so
I haven't looked at collagen peptides
from a joint perspective but I've looked
at it from a skin perspective and the
research I think I went over almost 20
studies on the topic and the research is
a little dicey there's some I guess
there's I'll put it this way there's a
mixture of studies some studies are
absolute crap and other studies are
decently well done so my meter if this
is the middle is leaning towards its
beneficials so I take 5 to 10 grams a
day and I think that's probably
applicable to
anyone and the benefits are in joint
health skin Health hair Health nail
Health like all that stuff yeah that's
I've I've specifically looked at skin
health so I know I know for a fact skin
Health but uh the the the idea is that
it also affects joint health as well
hair health for sure
absolutely yeah um I I actually take
quite a bit of collagen now because I
make my own protein pudding out of my uh
beef protein product and a collagen
product that I have and um I don't
really like drinking the shakes they
kind of taste too foamy so what I do is
I sort of blend them up refrigerate them
because it's got collagen it turns into
like a Jello-O pudding so it's really
good so I'll just like I'll smash one or
two of those a day so I'm taking quite a
bit of that so that's good I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement online books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out